- I think the homeless in general
just feel that they've
been completely forgotten
by society, that nobody cares about them.
Nobody cares if they wake up tomorrow.
They might even feel like they
think that people hope that
they don't wake up tomorrow.
And I didn't think that
anybody should have
to feel like that, so I decided
that when I became a PA, that I wanted
to focus on the homeless population.
(gentle, hopeful music)
(car door shutting)
(car starting)
So Street Medicine is
really a program that was born
out of the idea that everybody matters.
We see that there's certain
segments of the population that
just don't access healthcare
the way everybody else does.
(traffic speeding by)
(church bell rings)
Because Allentown is a
relatively small city,
it is still surrounded by woods so,
most of the homeless you're not gonna see
sleeping outside on the street
so they go live in the woods in tents,
so that's usually where we have
to go to find our patients.
I have a backpack with
over 20 medications.
We have a EKG machine.
We do point-of-care testing
where we can get different blood work.
The whole idea is to
deliver quality care on-site
in a place where the
patient feels comfortable.
(train horn honking)
(birds tweeting)
Do you still have that inhaler, Mike?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- How often are you using it?
- [Voiceover] 102 over 68.
- Everything we do is completely free.
We provide free medications, free labs,
free diagnostic studies, so
they don't need insurance,
and we have the same incredible people
that see them all the time.
They get to know us and trust us,
and we're lucky enough that
they allow us to help them.
Okay, just breathe normal.
Doing this job can be extremely difficult.
You just see things that are really hard
to see and sometimes feel helpless,
but one of the things that I always try
to do is just try and
completely forget myself in it,
to remember that this
is not about me at all.
It's just about the patients.
It doesn't matter if I'm tired.
It doesn't matter if I'm frustrated
with trying to help somebody.
It just doesn't matter about me.
It matters about them.
So I try and focus on
them and their needs.
(dry leaves and sticks
crunching under feet)